I'm he'll be going today we have a very
fun project this is the DJI spark and
you may be wondering why it's wrapped up
like this today I'm going to spray paint
this thing fluorescent pink one of the
best parts of all to spark other than
how small compact and absolutely
fantastic and perfect is it comes in
several other colors yellow blue green
red and white well why is there no pink
I'd mentioned my dad that I wanted to do
this and he was like let me wrap it up
and make sure that it is perfectly
covered and sealed before you do
anything there's very small tiny little
vents here so you definitely do not want
to be getting paint inside of that
because that will damage your drone and
back here is where the SD card slot is
and there's so many other fine Lu
details that I do not recommend doing
this at all
he took at the time this morning I was
sleeping and I woke up and he's like
alright got the drone all ready for you
to paint but now no
[Music]
they think this is exactly what we're
looking for but it definitely need to
use a white base coat so that's what
I'll do
[Music]
the colors that I've chosen is a
fluorescent hot pane they recommended to
put a top coat of white on before you
put the pink so that's what we're going
to do for you one last check before I do
the spray to make sure everything is
perfectly covered every little crevasse
is sealed and I think we're ready for
the first coat I've got our base coat of
white now and it's looking pretty good I
am so excited i pre-ordered the white
one again this is a prototype version
it's not the final version for man the
white is going to look so sick
[Music]
oh man it's looking so good loving
everything that's happening now little
let this dry and then we're going to
come back and check on it a little bit
since the next day and my dad actually
got up this morning and redid my paint
job because he said it wasn't very good
I didn't wait for the spray paint to dry
I'm a little bit impatient so he fixed
it up it's looking really good I still
have to highlight the DJI logo but I'm
going to take off the plastic wrap and
we're going to see what it looks like
[Music]
standing on the pod Chin's and I think
you spray paints that I got was kind of
a lie because this looks more red so if
you want to read drone you might as well
just buy the red drone my dad did such a
good job of taping us off thankfully he
was there to do this for me because you
guys know me this would have not worked
out well so let's take her for a flight
[Applause]
[Music]
Oh
I just ran around what do you think do
you like it well guys that's it thanks
for watching this is my sort of hot pink
DJI spark I'm so excited for this to
come out it'll be out on June 15 I got
the full bundle with all of the goodies
oh man I can't wait I'm probably gonna
have to go somewhere that weekend so
that me and my friends can all fly could
be like a quad drone trip somewhere in
the middle of nowhere alright guys
thanks for watching I'll see you later
I would advise trying this at home I was
definitely advised by adult supervision
my dad basically did the whole thing
because if he didn't you guys know that
this was not turned out well well we've
got some squished bugs up in here Oh bro
you